[Music]
that's interesting interesting that you
asked that question because we're really
dealing with that right now because we
have a we want to see since we know that
if you think about you Jen think about
the clitoris so think about the the
g-spot or think about the cervix that
those that the the corresponding part of
the body of the brain map for that those
parts of the body those become activated
so one question is whether women who can
think themselves to orgasm do they think
their genital activation the the brain
representation of the genitalia into act
into activity and does that spread to
the other systems that are involved in
orgasm how do they do it we want to
understand how they do it normally and
then the question is what if we ask
women to think about the genital the
genitals more intensively or will we
will we will they be able to intensify
the response in their genital sensory
cortex and will that spread to other
parts of the brain will that facilitate
their orgasm I mean I think it could be
very useful in in women who say that
they don't experience orgasms it could
be useful in women with spinal cord
injury who can't feel their their
external genitals can they can they
think their brain into greater
activation and will that facilitate
their orgasm that's a it's a it's a
question that we are currently dealing
with with our brain research and it's a
it's a very important and interesting
question and it could be therapy
therapeutically useful one of the
techniques that we that we've developed
is to have the women in the scanner
looking at their own brain activity in
near-real-time and the question is if we
can see our own brain activity in
near-real-time in specific regions can
we voluntarily increase the activity of
that part of the brain just by thinking
about
it just as as we can think about moving
our finger and we can we can move our
finger we can wiggle our finger we don't
know what we do we we learn to do it as
an infant because we got the feedback
between what we see and what we what we
do maybe we can do the same thing with
the brain if we see our own brain
activity maybe we can make a change and
maybe that's going to change the way we
feel or the way we move so this is a new
technology of near real-time brain
imaging and with unlimited frontiers we
don't really know how how far we can go
with it but it's a it's a new it's a new
approach